we knew you you'd come on our show years
and years ago before the hangover and
always a really funny guest and a great
performer then the hangover happened and
that must have changed your life
enormous ly hey well I mean yeah I mean
yeah it was it was weird to deal with it
but it's like show business is a it's a
blessing it's honey and it's poison and
it's you try to figure it out but you
know at the this town is like it's weird
because you if you get known you think
it's all great and respectful but it
never it never is respectful I was in a
was it a greeting card shop not too long
ago fine card all right sure of course
this woman comes up to me she goes uh
excuse me so are you are you an actor I
said yes ma'am
she said oh were you were you in those
hangover movies I said uh yes ma'am
she goes oh I heard you died is that
true
we walk away so it's never rewarding
it's never an out well it can be
rewarding and then when you're with the
minute you're riding high that somebody
yes that's right you real
you